coming into this video i noticed that
you've been particularly interested in
the list of 20 20 fights
so to give you a perfect gift i decided
that i'll be doing a second part of it
why well because believe it or not the
year 2020 still has a lot of awesome
anime fights that i didn't feature in
the first list
keep in mind i didn't include any fights
which i mentioned in the fall fights
video which i published recently so make
sure to check that video out if you
haven't done so already now i won't keep
you waiting and for this list i'll be
going through another series of 10
fights that you might want to look out
for it goes without saying that just
like the first video
this video will contain spoilers i'll
try to keep them down as much as i can
though
so that you can watch the video and go
and enjoy the featured anime in full
now this feels like a new thing a rail
gun fight that has miss saka playing the
antagonist role
against her is the unlikely pairing of
thorma and gunner to think of it the
level 0 and the level 5 make an
excellent complementary team
thorma takes care of the magical stuff
while gunai just smacks the physical
attacks around
still a dream team up like that finds
itself in a tough pickup against misaka
who continues on with her eisen-like
state of constantly evolving mid-fight
this fight got some cool moments like
thorma unleashing those dragons that
look out of place and so fitting in the
duwaru verse at the same time you know
misaka doesn't get enough credit but i
think that this fight shows just how
strong she really can be in the grand
scale of things
maybe because we just know misaka for
doing electromagnetic stuff and shooting
a laser beam from her finger
which looks underwhelming in a world
where the strongest people have reality
warping powers
but when you look at this fight it
pretty much took the mainline series
main character and two level fives to
bring her back to normal
not beta mind you just bring her back to
normal
[Music]
[Music]
one of the most awesome ass kicking this
2020 courtesy of one piece comes in the
form of
zorro vs camazo it's a brutal showdown
between multi-wielders that gave us some
of the best fight animations and
adaptations in this year for one piece
the anime did some retouching on this
scene which drew quite the divisive
reception from the fan base that
compared it to the manga nonetheless you
can't deny that the effects did add
quite a bit to the fight which is
already an amazing display of zorro's
prowess
catching up to one piece is a ginormous
task but now you know what's in store
the animation in the wano arc has been
pretty spot-on there's a reason why the
series is still one of the biggest ones
worldwide and while i don't think that
the fights are the primary reasons for
that
they sure play a decently major part
[Music]
sao's final alicization season had its
moments with its fights
and while i enjoyed a lot of them i
think that it would be a shame not to
include the finale on a top 10 list
on the first list i gave the nod to the
berkoli fight for the sheer awesomeness
of the cool uncle mentor character being
badass and it's breathtaking animation
however on a personal basis
this is the fight that i go back to once
in a while to re-watch
kirito versus sometimes is probably one
of the best finales a fan of the series
can ask for we get to see kirito firing
off the
culmination of all his experiences and
skills obtained in underworld as well as
updated callbacks to when the series was
the hottest thing in town
like the starburst dream while in his
signature old attire and don't tell me
you don't get a little bit emotional
when kirito took the thoughts and
prayers of every single living being in
underworld in the form of stars to
unleash his final attack
i think the one thing that seriously
holds this fight back is the lack of a
connection between the two combatants
they're just fighting each other for the
sake of protecting or destroying this
world and it would have been better
if somtalizer was someone kirito had a
personal stake with
four gil returns with a second fight to
make the list it's really telling when
your anime with less
episodes than one hand can count already
has two fights that i can claim are some
of the top fights in 2020
but fog hill of five elements did it but
today i'm featuring the bridge fight
which is really no slouch compared to
the one i featured on the previous list
if you recall i did feature this one on
yet another list but i think that it
just holds up so well to have it on
multiple lists even when you look at
2020 as a whole i still find this so
exhilarating and the fact that it's on a
show that's not being watched by many is
just the icing on top fog hill is not
a huge time investment so i really
encourage you to give it a try the story
is decent but when it comes to the
animation of fight scenes
it's outright top tier even in 2020 as a
whole
if you want me to name a hidden gem this
year with respect to the anime's overall
popularity and the quality of fight
scenes then hitori noshita would find
its way to the top of the list
it's a serious contender for topping
that list outright if you don't believe
me
let the clip do the talking for me then
to the animator's credit the research
really shows i honestly believe it's one
of the strongest points of the series
the guys doing the animating really know
their stuff in hitori noshita you can
really feel a sense of realism in its
combat scenes just watch and tell me if
you agree with what i see
you can really feel the impact of each
blow here if you consider yourself a
martial arts aficionado you might want
to try hitori no [ __ ] out however i'd
recommend not watching this just for the
fight and starting all the way back in
its first season
danwachi has its fair share of great
fights in its seasonal runs and this
year we got another treat in the form of
belle's fight against asterius
personally i think the bell really works
well as an underdog in his fights
and this one is no exception there's
just something about the plucky underdog
appeal that bell has
especially contrasted to the other
characters that his voice actor is
famous for voicing
it opens up a rarely seen intensity that
the voice actor does so well at
conveying
it really adds to the desperation that
the fight tries to present
great sound direction and excellent
animation make this one of the best
fights of 2020 no doubt
the fight itself is no slouch as well
people have been joking that this fight
is where the season's budget went and
you know what i actually agree
on another note this fight begs the
question of how many more times belle
and his favorite minotaur opponent
are gonna fight
fire force just ended but months before
it did it gave us an amazing fight with
joker fighting sol commander would it be
a pun to say that this season
of fire force has been lit i've always
liked the series and it didn't
disappoint with the overall improved
quality that this season has compared to
the first one
well i guess that's debatable i
personally like the developments more in
the first part but the second part gets
it right with the fights now enough of
that and i'll let you enjoy the actual
battle between
joker and soul commander this is a
particularly good one for me because
joker's one of my favorite characters in
the show and seeing him in action is
always a pleasing sight to behold
it also helps that the fight is full of
moments that will have you jumping out
of your seats or at least
widening your eyes just saying wow
joker's voice actor also
nailed it in this scene joker may or may
not be your favorite anti-hero
but his presence in fire force is a much
appreciated one
[Music]
2020 is my hero academia has had some
great fights after featuring endeavours
fight
it's time to look at deku vs overhaul
overhauls one tough cookie
and given how overpowered his abilities
are wondering how he would be defeated
is one of the things that kept me
watching the latest season of my hero
academia for one i knew that it had to
be deku to beat him as post shown in
anime standards but given how deku's
attacks play into the villain's
speciality
i was really curious as to how overhaul
would be beaten
turns out the old adage is true if you
don't beat someone the first time around
you're just not using enough firepower
thankfully deku got his from aries quirk
that allowed him to unleash one for all
at its full 100
finally breaking through overhaul's
regenerative capabilities
new form or not overcoming overhaul's
recovery cooldown with the rate of his
attacks deku was able to put down the
villain for good by just hitting fast
and hard
it may sound simple on paper but wait
till you see the scene i just had
goosebumps looking at how the fight
finished in the anime
and it's still a fight that i get back
to every now and then
[Music]
now let's take a look at jin versus
ilpio a fight that does its job in
encapsulating the craziness that goes on
in god of high school it's a battle
of the gods quite literally in this
showdown that features a lot of
grappling
striking transformations and two
fighters just throwing whatever
supernatural god powers they have at
each other it's a decently long fight
that has some cool stuff in it but
honestly speaking i'm more surprised
that the
ring remained intact after all of that
the story for god of high school might
not be too accurate of an adaptation of
the webtoon but the animation
is something to live for this my friends
is anime
in 2020 is it the best fight in the
series
well not for me i mean it's in the
second volume of the list not the first
but damn it's an awesome fight
[Music]
the biggest upstart in the shonen scene
deserves a featured fight on the list
while people have been raving over the
gojo fight for an extended period of
time i think that the fight against
mojito doesn't get enough credit it
didn't blow the internet up like gojo's
fight did but i would say that this
fight can go toe-to-toe with that one
and as a finale to the first part of jiu
jitsu kaizen i think he did a damn good
job
the previous fight shows us the first
major display of nanami's abilities when
he takes on mojito
in a chaotic fight that gets interrupted
he does get to show off his time-based
abilities and you've gotta wonder what
can top that
well it turns out it's having the main
character join the frey in a fight that
majito still looks to be in control of
despite the numbers disadvantage
throwing some god tier animation and
very creative powers and it comes as no
surprise how jujitsu kaizen
has quickly risen to the top of the
shonen anime rankings it's an amazing
finish too with yuji powering his way
into domain expansion
saving his mentor and finishing the
battle with a decisive victory
with that we end this list feel free to
comment on any other fights you think
deserve to be on this list
if you enjoyed content like this then
please like and subscribe
you can also check out my other channel
and subscribe to that one if you enjoy
video essays i'm looking forward to
seeing you again in the next one and
i'll see you next time
on vinnie tube
[Music]